ch monsieur Milan suite à vos exploits
de réunir orphelin et 3è âge j'aimerais
vous inviter pour l'été vous ainsi que
le personnel et T vos pensionnaires j'ai
une grande annonce à vous faire de
couper les cheveux non on part tous en
vacances à la
[Applaudissements]
mer bienvenue au belazure club
laissez-moi vous présenter quelquesuns
de nos pensionnaires voici laenzo
enchanté bonjour Ne vous fiez pas aux
apparences es sont ravies de vous
rencontrer ok W on part sur un wad on en
fait quoi de nouveau PIR débarquer des
vieux ça me fout un pied dans la tombe
moi génial c'est la Guer oh
çaomence ils vont s'entretuer leses ça
va être trop
[Musique]
bien
qutier non mais oh ça va pas bien ou
quoi là on va dire à Milan de nous
ramener dans notutre foyer là-bas c'est
chez nous la vérité c'est qu'on peut pas
rentrer au foyer vous avez 15 jours
passez ce délai je serai obligé de
replacer vos pensionnaires dans un
orphulina et maison de retraite digne de
ce nom si les anciens ont séparé des
enfants c'est ça qui les tuera ensemble
ils sont une famille c'est beau la
manière dont tu t'occupes des anciens
milans le bonheur on fait le tour du
monde pour le trouver et c'est souvent
après qu'on sait qu'il était là
Christophe May et c'est souvent après
qu'on sait qu'il était là allez
[Musique]
on
tiens prends ça ça va
[Musique]
[Rires]
détendre